my eyes are down here curtly you can do
it this is why you don't let guys play
with Roger what do I know about bra
prices they're expensive erections I
have zero life experience that just led
me to this moment I bet we have a good
time
wow it's got a nice wire support it
feels like it's not break I feel like it
would be cheap this has a lot of
intricate and lacing I'm guessing
sixty-five dollars fifteen bucks 20
bucks
I'd say twenty four dollars fifty two
dollars
4235 what a steal this looks like a
really nice fancy bra I guess what we
learned is I'm usually impressed
oh is this a bra this one seems cheap to
me I've seen like some nice bra less
this ain't one of them oh it's free
people knots nothing at all does this
change your opinion on how much it costs
no I still think it costs a lot oh I can
feel your heartbeat $65 no 29.95 I'm
gonna go ahead and say $30 it's free
people send us at 50 26
72 $70
oh wow you're destroying me that's too
much
this is kind of fancy I actually for
some reason feel like this is cheap
I would not disgrace my boobs with this
bra I found that with like women's
clothing less material means more
expensive the fact that it's so easy to
take off tells me that it's cheap this
could be like a boutique I'm gonna $12
4550 $5 $60 $12 $27 I was so wrong dang
I would never spend a few dollars in a
pair of underwear but thinking oh my
under head like holes in it you know do
you have to pay more the bigger your
boobs are $22 $55 635 112 I'm shooting
for the stars 89 bras cost a whole bunch
of money and it's kind of nonsense what
cost what I'm glad I don't want the by
bra okay feel very bad that women have
to spend that much other things that you
need the cheapest bra is still more than
I ever spent on a single pair of boxer
briefs if something makes you feel sexy
to wear it wear it if you don't care
about that don't wear it don't wear a
bra at all
I don't get it as fine as your boobs
we're just pretending not to look at
them
do you think I'm pulling it off I think
you should pull it off yeah